remember a couple years ago how
everybody was talking about that a
market crash was coming I've done a
couple videos on that everybody's like
oh my God what if it happens what if it
doesn't now everybody's talking about
it's going to be soft Landing there's
not going to be any recession and
there's one thing that people forgot
about the saying only the paranoid
surviv so people are not it's totally
fine look at the market it's near
all-time Highs but is it really if you
were to pull out the top seven stocks
when you see the numbers on this it's
staggering and on top of that there is
an indicator of when a recession
actually hits and it isn't while we're
raising interest rates the FED it
happens after we stop raising rates and
wait till you see how long it takes for
the market to crash and by the way I got
a bunch of other data to share with you
but uh I've learned one thing for sure
having been in the financial industry
since the day before 9/11 only the
paranoid survive and those who are way
too confident are typically wrong and
those who are way too cocky are also
typically wrong okay so if you give Al
out of this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel let's get
right into it so here's us interest rate
hikes in the history of of America when
we raise rates we have never raised
4.88 percentage points as quickly as we
did in the state so if you look at this
here the yellow to the left shows how
quickly we kept increasing rates and
you'll see the lowest was from 2015 to
2018 when we raise two points then
you'll see 1999 to 2000 we raised 1.51
and you'll see 2004 to 2006 over two
years we raised roughly Four Points 94
to 95 2.67 88 to 89 3.3 but nothing
comes close to the 22 to 23 of 4.88 but
what does this really mean so if we look
at the balance sheet of this is pretty
much the quantitative easing balance
sheet if you look at the top that shows
how much bonds the FED is buying but if
you look at the bottom the M2 money
supply shows how much money is
circulating in the economy so you notice
if you go to 2020 look how historically
it's gradually climbing climbing
climbing but it's nothing that's sudden
then all of a sudden boom we feed the
economy the market with trillions of
dollars we're not accustomed to and we
don't have another case study for
somebody to say well here's what's going
to happen well it's totally okay well
don't worry about it based on what based
on what case study can you speak so
confidently saying nothing's going to
happen so look I've been in the
financial industry since 9/11 the day
before 911 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my network in
gold that I have access to in case of
many different things a few facts you
need to know about gold number one the
gold market cap is 11.8 trillion since
2000 the compound annual growth rate for
gold has been
9.24% and during times of high inflation
3% plus has been
15.35% now those are just some numbers
for you but there's some other benefits
to add gold to your portfolio number one
hedge against inflation number two
results showed recently that 90 83% of
central banks are working on AC cbdc so
this means what that could be a
manipulated currency that they own if
you own gold it's a non duplicatable
asset you're now hedging against cbdc
taking place number three a potential
cyber threat if it happens you don't
have access to your money you don't have
access to your accounts well you have
access to your hard physical gold number
four is anonymous no one knows you have
that gold and last but not least
diversification that's why we chose to
work with our new sponsor American
Hartford gold if you have retirement
funds that you cannot afford to lose
American Harford gold will ship physical
gold or silver directly to your door
also if you have retirement funds that
you can't afford to lose now is the time
to call American Harford gold a precious
metal dealer you can trust they have the
finest products amazing customer service
and a buyback commitment they've earned
a five-star rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau tell them I send you and
they'll send you up to $5,000 worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on a link in the description or call 866
93969 84 again
6984 everybody is almost protecting
whatever business they're part of
investment they have they're trying to
sell why they're right and maybe don't
worry about it or do worry about it but
the reality of it is nobody knows 100%
what's going on cuz we've never been
here before so let's continue so then
2024 projections what's next for the US
economy they did a survey to find out
who thinks a recession is coming look to
the left the FED staff says 0% there's
not going to be a recession I remember
they're in the business so they're
supposed to be saying that because that
is Wall Street right yield curve says
61% chance of recessions coming next 12
months economists are at 48% consumers
are at 69% that's Main Street you and I
Goldman Sachs is saying only 15% Bank of
America 35 to 40% but look at CEO 84%
okay seets are saying 84% now what would
cosos know that rest of them don't know
maybe they know their debt payment maybe
they know when their debt payment
interest rates that they got was lower
that if they have to renew the debt that
they got it's going to go up here how
the hell are we going to make those
payments maybe we ought to looking what
some of these cosos are talking about
and if you go to the bottom you'll
notice the percentage of S&P 500
companies citing keywords on earning
calls look at What's happen from Q2 2022
to Q2 2023 what words they're using
fewer times inflation has decreased
material cost decreased economical
slowdown decreased job Cuts went up but
it's also decreased so could this be a
sign that everything's going to be okay
if yes why are CEOs at
84% saying a recession is coming are
they Houdini are they Nostradamus are
they somebody that can predict the
future what do they know that the rest
of the people don't know now when it
comes on to S&P 500 these are the 500
biggest companies in America something
very interesting is happening there are
seven companies that make up
28% of the S&P 500 let me break this
down for you 500 biggest companies seven
companies make make up 28% in the
history of S&P 500 never has there been
a time where seven companies make up 28%
we've never had seven companies you know
too big to fail we've never had seven
companies now what are these companies
you got meta Facebook Nvidia Apple
Microsoft alphabet Amazon and Tesla so
why is this important here's why if you
look at the S&P 500 yourto date returns
you will notice a number roughly around
12.4% could be higher could be lower but
it's not 12% you know what magnificent
7's return is for the year so far
roughly 92% so what happens if you take
the seven stocks out and there's only
493 stocks left how's the S&P 500 doing
it's down so the seven are pulling the
rest of the market and it looks like
everything else is okay but is it really
so we decided to break it down to see
how small cap companies were doing
midcap companies were doing versus large
cap companies and you will notice a
trend here watch this okay so if you
look at this chart you'll notice three
different funds here one is the Spy
which is the S&P 500 the other one is
the Russell 2000 then you have the micro
cap ETF so if you look at these the S&P
500 is companies valued roughly at 12.7
billion or higher top 500 biggest
companies in America Russell 2000 is
company size is $300 million to $2
billion market cap and then the micro
cap is from 50 million to 300 million so
if you look at this what do you notice
you'll notice spy is up
18.66% the rich get Rich the big get
bigger the stronger get stronger great
Russell 2000 is only up 7% but look at
the micro cap micro cap companies are
down
1.85% so why is that is it the bigger
guys can afford to go through a season
like this they can weather the storm and
it can kind of handle because the amount
of cash they have and capital they have
and the smaller guys cannot possibly but
we cannot fool ourselves thinking the
market is up just because these seven
magnificent companies are carrying the
we so so far the reason why the market
hasn't crashed is one magnificent 7 is
holding the S&P 500 high so people are
like it's going to be okay number two
unemployment is super low 50-year low so
people have jobs they're paying their
bills they're not really that worried
about it they are worried but not that
worried about it to the point that the
market has to think about maybe a crash
or recession coming around the corner
however number three something to be
concerned about because the US consumer
credit card debt tops a trillion dollars
so you may say Pat credit card debt
trillion dollars I get it it's the
highest it's ever been in the history of
America it's not like that's that big of
a deal we've been spending money on
credit cards for a while fine no problem
but look at this chart tell me if this
concerns you a little bit this is the
credit card interest rate this shows you
let me explain what the differences are
blue is the credit card rate orange is
the 5year US Treasury the gray is the
difference between the two so look at
credit card interest rates is the
highest it's ever been because as rates
go higher your interest rate on your
credit card goes higher and then it
makes you miss payments more so if you
had a $33,000 credit card total debt and
it keeps going higher and higher and
higher your payments are getting bigger
and bigger and bigger the average person
is like look I can afford to pay 300
bucks a month I can't afford to pay $420
a month all of a sudden it went up or a
bigger number than that $420 now it's
$580 but this is not a good sign of
what's taking place because people's
interest payments are officially higher
than they've ever been before now for
some of you guys that are watching this
I don't want to break it to you I got
some bad news for you you know the 30 40
million students or Americans who were
paying their debt for their student loan
remember that whole where the the
government said yeah during Co don't
worry about making the payments we're
going to defer this in October those
things are coming back so think about 30
to 40 million people having to pay
another $300 per month that starts this
month so put that on top of everything
else that's going on another 300 bucks a
month now this next one's going to be
crazy because this next one some people
could say p this is why the Market's not
going to crash and I'll give you the
argument let me show it to you so if you
look at this chart what this shows is
the weighted average mortgage rate So
currently mortgage rates are well over
7% and in some cases at 8% about 4% or
5% higher than the lowest mortgage rates
we had set earlier in 2022 so this is
like a year and a half ago we're around
3% today we're at say 7 and 1 12 8%
despite the sharp increase in interest
rates the weighted average rate has
barely ticked up only those buying
houses are affected by no mortgage rates
and there aren't many home buyers so
what this means is the way that if you
take everybody's mortgage loan
everybody's loan together and you
averaged weighted rate that they have it
has an increased cuz people are not
refinancing the the refi business is
dead today right only the people that
buying a new house are paying these new
high rates and people are not buying as
many houses as they did before because
people are not selling cuz those who are
not wanting to sell they don't want to
go from a 3% loan to an 8% loan you get
the idea how long this can last no one
knows but they're still hanging on to
that loan saying I'm not giving up this
3% loan okay so that was a breather I
gave you some bad news that's a student
loan you got to paid reminded you were
kind of upset then I give you some good
news this is the real news you want to
know about why the market hasn't tanked
it when you look at this chart this is
the Fed funds and the lag effect the lag
the delayed lag effect the graph below
shows the FED fund rat and the time is
as measured in months from the last in a
series of rate hikes preceding each
recession since 1981 so meaning they're
increasing the rates increasing
increasing increasing increasing
increasing boom they stop racing how how
long did it take until recession hit if
you look at these numbers you'll see a
six a 15 months 8 months 17 months 10
months you know what that means takes
roughly 11 months from the moment we
stop raising interest rates that
recession appears again if this data is
real say they raised the interest rates
next month the month of November okay
let's go 11 months December January
February March April May June July
August September October of 2024 a month
before election there should be a
recession in America based on this chart
that's what should happen in 11 months
from November now some people may say
well Pat how come more corporations are
not filing bankruptcy how come all this
stuff that happened in 2008 is not
happening today because these
corporations if you look at this chart
what they were doing is the money they
took companies were taking millions and
billions from Banks saying go get some
more money from the bank cuz it's so
cheap what do we do with the money just
set it aside who cares we go get the
money yeah but the rates are only locked
for 3 years or two years or four go get
50 million go get a billion go get 100
million and they did so what did these
corporations do they took that $50
million at 3% and they bought bonds so
the difference let's just say the bonds
paying 6% the 6% 3% the 3% they're
making on top of us okay make we're
making 3% on 50 million Buck every year
we're making million and a half in
interest this is awesome we should have
borrowed more money however if you look
at this chart you know what's coming up
here's what's coming up when that
expires and it matures and then it goes
from 3% to 8% they're going to be in
deep trouble because they have to make
those payments they can no longer make
money on that so what do they do that's
when they have to say hey we don't want
this loan anymore Let me give it back to
you if they have the money or two bank's
going to say we're expecting a payment
do you have it can we wait another month
can we wait another two months this is
why a company called weor that was
valued at $47 billion in 2017 where soft
Bank gave it
$18.9 billion investment just defaulted
on a $95 million payment this month we
were we haven't seen a lot of this yet
this is coming soon so so let me unpack
this lag effect of these corporations
having to pay their interest on the loan
that they took so look take a look at
this chart if you look at this chart
this is Corporate debt maturing in
billions of dollars to the left so if
you look at the remainder of 2023 you'll
notice they have roughly another 220
$230 billion of interest payments left
to pay they're going to end up paying
roughly $520 $ 5 billion in 2023 of
corporate debt maturing this is the
entire year of 2023 but look what it's
projecting to go in 20124 roughly 790
billion matures how much does it mature
in 25 1.1 trillion and then it goes to
roughly 1.2 trillion give or take 2027
stays at a trillion 2028 goes closer to
1.3 trillion how are they going to go
all of a sudden from 2 3 4500 billion to
a trillion to 1.4 1.4 trillion 1.5
trillion and this is why when we asked
the question at the beginning who is the
least optimistic about recession 84%
CEOs maybe they know something that
others don't because they know that debt
is coming so so far we've talked about
imagine the average individual is like
look dude you might school loan I got to
pay for now that credit card debt went
up all of a sudden to the highest that's
ever been DED I can't afford these
payments and you're noticing the
defaults right now you know commercial
commcial real estate companies are
defaulting on their payments subprime
Auto Finance so those people that don't
have good credit that bought a car
they're starting to default with their
payments cuz they interest rates are
going up they're default and they can't
afford a pay it right now but who else
is experiencing this well these were all
small things we're talking about right
you know who else owes a lot of money
what Corporation in the world owes the
most money you know what that
Corporation is called the Great United
States of America you know what's going
to happen to them every time interest
rates go up let's break it down for you
so us roughly owes $33 trillion of
national debt math would tell you and I
that each 1% increase in interest rates
pushes the government's interest expense
up by you know how much $320 billion
each per each 3% is a trillion dollar
just interest increase not total an
increase of an additional $3 trillion at
each 3% so just to kind of put that in
context if you look at this chart look
what it shows you this is the interest
expense we've had in us from 1970 till
today you know how it's gradually gone
up gone up up gone up but it's not not
been anything crazy then look at Co boom
boom Skyrocket it how are we going to
make these payments I have no clue but
they're going to come to you and I cuz
it's really our debt the government is
we the people you and I are running you
know we hired these people to run this
Corporation but they come to you and I
to fund it so guess who they're coming
to very soon you and I you know there's
certain things you look at to be
motivated and excited about the future
you may want to skip this next chart you
but take a look at this chart here so
again remember this Corporation we're
talking about called the United States
of America here's what this is the green
is the tax revenue our government gets
every year from you and I the Orange is
our GDP the blue is our interest payment
and the red is our debt the $33 trillion
debt look how many many years ago in
1980 everything was right next to each
other just 43 years ago they're neck and
neck all of a sudden Boom the red goes
off to the roof look it just skyrockets
all the way to the top GDP is a gradual
growth and guess what all of a sudden
caught up to being the second highest
now it's our interest expense this is
not good news this is why every time
these guys don't want to go get their
you know balance their budget except
they want to spend money and people say
well it's okay well it's okay well it's
okay you're just telling them don't do
your job it's okay keep spending money
I'm okay with that this is our doing cuz
we voted these people in you and I voted
these people in and they're managing
Us's finances in a reckless way okay so
if you're watching this same pad so
what's your point do do do you want me
to start my day being worried should I
be stressed out someone just shared this
video with me and I'm sitting here
saying the hell is this all about am I
supposed to now lock it up and just not
spend any money not do anything here's
all I'm saying to you is I subscribe to
the concept of only the paranoid survive
I'll give you a story and wrap it up
last night Sunday night I'm playing
Monopoly with my two sons and my
daughter one of my sons decides to play
very conservative and he's keeping and
hanging on to all the cash he's not
buying any properties like like no no no
so he's got the most cash one of my sons
every time he gets cash he's building a
house I'm going to build three houses on
Indiana Kentucky and this I'm going to
build three houses on Vermont this and
this and this and we're like dude this
guy's down to $200 and then we land on
it oh you owe me
320 okay hope you owe me 320 it's my
turn I'm going to buy two more houses
and I want to build on this okay boom
well you owe me 550 I thought it was 320
I buil two more houses I'm going to go
build now hotels okay how much is it oh
you owee me 900 damn and guess what you
don't have any money I'll take that
Parkplace from you but that's not fair
or you can do so all of a sudden he's
got Parkplace Boardwalk he's got all
everything going on right now I want to
be Parkplace and guess who lands on
Boardwalk Daddy I land on Boardwalk you
know how much Boardwalk is $22,000 that
I don't have so I got to give him four
railroads and luckily I was able to
negotiate a good deal I give him
electricity I give him all this stuff
and I got to give him a couple you know
properties that I have have and next
thing you know you know who ends up
winning the guy that took a little bit
more risks than my other son did and he
wins the game of Monopoly what does this
mean does it mean go spend all your
money right now no all it means is if
your tolerance for risk isn't High don't
take it but don't expect to make a lot
of money if you're going to be super
conservative but if you have some
tolerance for risk this may be a good
time for you to be shopping certain
things because the next 3 6 12 months
people may be very scared and FYI don't
let the arrogance of people saying
everything's going to be okay the
Market's not going to crash it's going
to be a recession soft Landing whenever
anybody says that including myself just
kind of say I don't think anybody knows
what they're talking about I'm just
willing to listen to everybody all I
know is only the paranoids survive
having said that if you got value out of
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel if you've never seen a
video on the dollar collapsing highly
recommend you watch this video click
here to watch it take care everybody
bye-bye